hello everyone I'm Mary and welcome to
another gamespot plays I'm here with the
lovely Kevin Bernard all and we are
going to play one of our favorite games
of all time yes you haven't noticed its
own lightest journey and this is such a
magical game it came out in 2012
originally reviewed by Jim Douglas I
think Jay Douglas gamespot but it was
also coveted with gamespot's game of the
year award in 2012 but is back because
is now recently released this week on
ps4 yeah and one of my favorite games of
all time and I think a legitimate you a
game we would legitimately call one of
the best games ever made I agree and
this is on so many of our top five games
of all time I mean it's just kind of
overwhelmingly known as a game that just
is enjoyable to so many different types
of people everyone enjoys this game yeah
you like shooters you still like this
game if you like RPGs you still like
this game it just appeals to so many
different moments this moment I mean
it's one of many many moments in this
game where we're just the that moment
that particular site just stays with you
and that is one of 45 indelible sites
and journey and now a little bit of sand
surfing yeah there was a technically
they had done something really
tremendous with the sands to make it
feel so incredibly real I really loved
the way that they made the sand look and
feel with the character merely made you
feel like you were a part of this world
and they do that a lot with their
environments in this game I mean if
there's one complaint that I have
sometimes heard about this is you know
wouldn't this work just as well as a
movie as it is a game since it's it's
more about the the audio visual
stimulation and I say no I say
absolutely not you need to be able to
get into that sand and and
feel it for yourself you need to be able
when you get your scarf which we're
about to earn right here to feel that
joy of floating well the major
difference between anytime someone would
say wouldn't this make a better movie
well if the key component of the game is
interaction see interaction that the
player has with the game to have their
impact their say that that separates it
from something that is passive which is
a film you were just observing a film
whereas you are playing this game you
were able to be more immersed in the
idea that you are you are able to go
anywhere you want you make the decisions
in this game and that's really true
there is a story that you're following
but at the same sense you don't have to
do a lot of things their achievements
that you would never even realize that
you can do there's hidden flowers in
this game there's hidden discoveries and
you find friends along the way you can
choose to play the game with or not yeah
totally I mean you you know the online
was quite something and the way that
works is that you're just randomly
paired with somebody you don't know what
their their online name is they're just
suddenly there a lot of the time and
then you take the journey your exist in
the same space whether or not you decide
that this person has somebody to ignore
or somebody that you'll you'll try to
communicate with just depends on who you
are and but there are moments where you
you develop this this unspoken
connection with that person there's
there's a point later in the game where
there actually is you know there are
points where there is danger and the
first time I ever played journey
there was another player who succumbs to
that danger and you know you watch you
watch your companion fall and lose a
chunk of scarf which is like which is
essentially your lifeline in this world
that scarf and so seeing seeing him or
her lose that bit of scarf is just was
just devastating to me and it's it's the
power of this game to to make moments
like that happen all wordlessly yep it's
a huge achievement that this game can
make you care about someone that you
know nothing about there is enormous
amounts of emotion to people that you do
not know that you've never spoken a word
to and how communication can even happen
without words is just an enormous
achievement in my opinion when when you
look at the way that I'll tell you a
story the first time I ever played this
game I also you know when I was running
around with my companion hit a longer
scarf of me which is a representative of
their history in the game longer the
scarf typically they have more knowledge
about the game they've been playing it
for longer they found more pieces and so
on and they there's only one way you can
interact with people and that's like
your little ding your little noise that
you can make and that's it you don't be
me me me me me so we had just finished a
smaller puzzle and I knew the next way
out I could see it and I was going there
and he kept dinging at me and he
wouldn't he wouldn't follow me yeah and
so i dinged a bunch back and said it's
over here and i remember being a little
obnoxious about it like so we're here
stupid like I've already found it you
know here's visit he was trying to help
you adamant that I didn't that we didn't
go so I said all right what do you want
and I follow him and sure enough there
was a little secret underneath the
staircase that I would never have seen
if he didn't show it to me not only did
I learn I mean that's an enormous lesson
to learn without words not only that he
was able to communicate that to me but I
also was quite humbled by the fact that
he knew more than me and he patiently
waited for me right to come around to
understand that maybe heat there was
something to be said and there was
nothing more of it there was there was
no animosity no aggression I learned a
valuable lesson and then we continued
our journey together that was a really
beautiful moment that you can have with
another person with absolutely zero
words but yet so much communication yeah
this this games excellent that chirp can
mean so much you can be little chirps
but it's also again it's part of your
your life force and if another player is
close to you you can or you you know you
let out a large Church your replenishing
each other's Jan scarves and you can see
here like in the end the scarf is your
key to jumping it needs to be you know
you need to have some mojo in that scarf
in order to make leaps like that and now
one of my favorite moments if we had
another player it would be even more
fantastic to me is when you walk up to
these stones and then depending on on
how you feel about it you could say that
you're sitting down to pray or you're
sitting down to meditate but either way
it's this incredible moment and your
then taken into a lesson that you're
being taught you know what is the
history of this place service this
figure relates to you essentially what
happens next and what happened
next we had already kind of played
around with the idea that there are a
lot of religious tones in this game
whether or not you choose to look at it
from that perspective but without a
doubt you're looking at history of a
large place you're taking a journey at
which you are hoping to get to the
destination and it all kind of fulfills
itself in this climactic conclusion
where you feel like you have gone on
this long journey and now you are on the
next step the next journey if you will
and that's something that a lot of games
i think failed to do with such well they
do it quite delicately it's not rest on
you this is something that you can
choose how you how you want to take it
in and I think that's another reason why
it appeals to so many different types of
people because you get to decide what it
means to you and it can have any meaning
at all yeah totally I am I think even if
it doesn't connect with you and I know
people that it doesn't connect with on
an emotional level here I mean I
consider Carolyn Pettit to be one of the
my best friends and in all of an all
life and she doesn't feel that when she
plays journey
and and I but I do think that even aside
from that even if you don't connect in
that way it's still hard not to admire
the way the game feels under the fingers
the way it looks the way it sounds it's
absolutely gorgeous whether or not it
moves you on a fundamental level I think
that it's difficult to to deny that it's
gorgeous and that it feels good to play
and that it's you know it's appealing
but I but I do feel like you know those
of us who are lucky to enough to develop
that connection we have you know there's
something we have something special and
now a companion is here yeah this is
where I first met my companion we built
a bridge together is like the first
puzzle yeah we used to work together
with someone and you know when you look
at the large scope of this game I mean
look at this large area this was really
a technical marvel that they put this on
the ps3 it kind of still surprises me
how much they packed into this game and
made it look so flawless if it looks
like you could just go on forever but I
want to point out some things here that
I don't think people would necessarily
see when they talk about you know hey
this could just be a movie things like
don't do did you see the way the camera
panned out to make sure that both me and
my companion were in the shot you know
there's enough room here where the
camera can fill out and have those
moments like like here the way that I'm
still use your still interacting with
the game even as the scene plain grey it
is a cinematic moment at the same time
you and your companion are out doing
things right now and interacting with
each other could you uh did you chirp at
informa
you get back yeah totally i'll chirp
but even here you see the way the
cameras pull back and then when your
companion is off of the screen it gives
you a little glue to the glow it's not
an arrow it's not and this part here is
there's a there's a secret up there
there's a glowy I think he wants
let's go with him
they did I mean there was just so many
things they did well but it's a it's a
tremendous way to feel relaxed while
solving things totally you always feel
at peace in this game the music the
score is just I mean just amazing
beginning to end I think it's like more
the best musical compositions for a game
I've ever heard oh yes Austin wintry is
as the composer
I'm proud to have met Austin before to
have seen him speak at GDC to to talk
with him and had done stories with him
and he's just an astounding individual
and beyond that I I think he is the best
the best composer working in games today
and I think that's saying something
art student games and you can see the
wind interacting with the sand and
making it almost look like fluid water
yep it's really beautiful
jilla buddy yeah it's a it's a happy
moment another story from the first time
I ever played this game I mundo my
second playthrough I had a buddy and we
for whatever reason decided to
continuously chirp it each other nonstop
the entire playthrough and I don't just
mean like once every in a while I mean
like thinking dignity the entire game
and you'd think that'd be annoying but
when you have two people that both enjoy
chirping we were just like super in sync
with each other and I felt like this
very deep connection with stranger that
had decided that chirping was just as
cool as I thought it was so much so that
we never stopped the entire time there's
a part later on where it does get a
little bit it gets a little sadder you
start to get worried about you and your
your buddies health and well-being
you're against the elements and the
entire time we chirped nonstop to let
each other know that we were there and
it meant something to me so much so that
you will remember these moments long
after you play there was a glowy and I
wanted to go get the glowy before give
it a little sure Peru
there it is
and of course replenishing your your
scarf is a big part of this because you
need to you know you need to fill it up
so that you can so that you can leave
right there is slow there's an emotional
part 2 if there's also just a technical
aspect to it right which is that it
helps you travel farther to get further
in the game you guys have almost
completely built the bridge there is a
totally bring it now there is an
achievement to crossing without come
without great yeah there's a few
achievements that I'd like to get we've
never had that opportunity there's one
coming up where you surf on the sand if
you can get through all the difference
I'll try the the wordless bit it's like
in Dark Souls I think there's this sense
of camaraderie that you break if the
players themselves it interact directly
through words that's interesting there's
something to be said about that and I
know there's a lot of developers that
always think as soon as you can interact
with another player chances are you're
probably when you do something to harm
them that's like a natural thing right
like if you if you can meet someone in
an open world you you might
instinctively try to mess with that
lawyer yeah negatively impact them and
they have to restrict that but it is no
way to do that in this game you can't
harm other people you can perhaps I
suppose you could lead them to harm in a
couple levels or lead them on a wild
goose chase like I just did with my poor
with my for companion you had better can
I did have the best intentions um and
now more wordless story you get an idea
of what happened here
this is I mean I think it's important to
mention that this is that journey
depicts essentially a post-apocalypse
you know a post-apocalyptic wasteland
and but what what what beauty came from
that and even here like I get this sense
of a you know there's a sense of a
bustling metropolis here you know as far
as I can tell this is a you know this is
public transportation more or less and
you know you get the idea of a place
that it was a but it was alive right at
least that's how I've always interpreted
this particular scene like a busy
downtown area yeah and what's
interesting then is when you sort of
slide through that area in journey what
might be journeys most memorable moment
it's just all the more indelible hmm
it's all delivered with a really
delicate art style as well that works
really well with the way this game is
played which is almost done in a wall
painting yes way which I really enjoy it
matches the direction the environment
and you know kind of like this Adobe
style painting with the sand it was
really well together it's very
hieroglyphic yeah um but I think it's
important to note if you've never played
journey that okay this is one of several
iconic images again in journey this
moment here you with your bud this
moment was my desktop background for the
longest time
look at you with that other dude just
hanging out and now some sand surfing
such a fun part it really is how often
do you say we when you fight again I
don't really say it I think it in a way
but I feel like we isn't necessarily a
journey kind of emotion my emotion
that's how I played it and now you're
sort of introduced to your ear creature
buddies for the first time and he helps
in a number of ways one is that he'll
keep your scarf replenished and then he
digs into the sand like that which i
think is adorable and there are times
where he'll in this really funny way
he's also a guide as you can see but
he'll also sometimes just pick you up
like like you well not quite there but
there are times where he'll pick you up
and then that sets up some puzzles that
come later hmm I think it's also
important to note that the game has
established with just its visual
language that that mountain is rearing
yeah it does it from the second you
begin a game I've never seen that in a
game before where the second you're
dropped off I know what my end goal of
the entire game is in the first second
without a word yeah that's the other
thing all of this is wordless
it's quite an achievement to be able to
do so much with no communication I I was
very fortunate to be at the e3 where
this was announced and shown to press
for the first time and it made such here
we go i got a little ride see check that
out all right king of the ribbons right
and then he just drops me off you're
done there's no free ride for everyone
so beautiful but anyway Jenova Chen was
there and talking about what they were
going for from the game and the
inspiration was nothing like what you
actually see on the screen it was a
month it was emotional inspiration he
knew what kind of emotion he wanted
people to feel when they played and it
was inspired by what astronauts talk
about when they go to the moon and they
see they looked down and they see the
earth beneath them and it's humbling and
melancholy and you feel small and alone
and he wanted to to sort of approach
that emotion in videogame form one shift
to find a way to to do that and I think
he did a really good job of doing
exactly that
how could you describe where you would
get the melancholy or a bittersweet
feeling from that this comes you in
terms of the space dude or just in terms
of the game well the feeling that he's
trying to invoke I find that fascinating
that that's what you would get when you
would look down at the earth I've never
i think it's just i think it's very
humbling you look down and you realize
how small the earth is and then you
realize how small everything is and how
tiny and sort of insignificant you are
and yet i think at the same time there's
there's something powerful about that in
the sense that you know like here you
have a companion you there's
togetherness to be found in the void and
i think that's ultimately a big part of
this game is you know the togetherness
that you find in the void and again it's
one of those marvelous things of this
game
manages to capture at least for me and
here's one of those moments where and i
love that the how its taught you that
that's a possibility very subtly earlier
when you first encounter those creatures
that they might give you a ride and then
that's all you need to know that
information right there was was all you
needed to know very solve this little
puzzle they introduced a new game
mechanic without you actually needing to
use it yet just so you could just be
introduced to it
I don't think we're too far and they're
all trapped in here and it's actually
heartbreaking right now even if you
don't know or understand or care about
the circumstance I think there's
something you just instinctively know
that they're trapped in there they're
calling out but luckily they don't
remain that way as you see in a little
really just a moment set them free I
really I love that you're maybe not the
standard type of hero in this game right
you're very subtle calm collected and
I'm not it's funny because when I play
this game i'm not a typical gamer either
i fight you know obviously a lot of
people they're going to chase
achievements they're going to go for all
all the hidden areas they're going to do
all of that stuff but i see those things
as you know if they add to the emotion
of the game that's great but i don't go
out of my way to do that again because I
don't you know it's not the gayest game
in all the world although there are bred
you know breadcrumb trails to follow but
what I get out of it is different than
you know another game where I'm going
after a bunch of collectibles say yeah
the achievements are almost out of place
in this game because I would find it
weird to just search for a desert flower
as opposed to just enjoying my
experience right in the game but
everybody is such a different kind of
game player and I'm glad that it's there
for people that that want that and now
we've you know essentially now we've
we've released them from what I've
always envisioned is there the prism of
these Souls and now we get a ride
yeah this is a lovely moment
you got any bud I think so it's hard to
tell how do tell I couldn't tell if that
was actually a weird visual glitch for a
moment or whether at that moment I was
connected with someone else and now
we're getting to the to several more
scenes I think this is now the Sam
surfing scene because my favorite scenes
this is the this is the scene that um
you know in most games you'll have a
moment where you say holy crap and this
was it for me and now I'm gonna try to
go through gates to get that achievement
after all our discussions are all the
decision just now not getting
achievements get that achievement Kevin
no no I think it's uh I think like 12 of
them so it's not easy yeah I'm probably
not gonna do it but Oh seeing there was
a glowy over there that I missed that's
right i remember when i first played
this I went out of my way to try to get
the glowy and then a lot of times you
can just enjoy this ride like what a
wonderful gorgeous it feels so good it's
oh yeah this is for all the fans and and
here we go teen games like snow oh where
where it gets everybody on camera pulls
away and you get this moment and its
just oh this game and there's a there's
a glowy up there that I'm gonna try to
get which you can get maybe maybe at
least see if I can get any of the all
right go through so many the achievement
oh I should have stayed over here maybe
and then gone off
like surfing on gold it's really
stunning I'm sorry I know we have to
stop it's just I can't with this game
it's just so hard in a way like I love
it so much I love your little companions
to not your main one but the little guys
that have helped you now throughout the
way they're just enjoying themselves and
their new freedom makes you feel really
good and I don't know that I'm gonna
make the achievement because I turned
out after all that I earlier i turn off
notifications so that they wouldn't be
annoying during now in our heart well no
because I'll look after we're done but I
went through as many gates as life I
think I could it's not as though that
was much of a challenge a lot of them
use need to go through them and find out
that the bear ok and here again v for me
this is the best moment of journey we
all have our favorites but this is my
favorite moment of journey is this scene
I'm glad we got to show this
mmm I was just an accident hitting that
ramp like that few little leaps just and
then once more out a little bit more
surfing
then the surfing ends
but that that golden bit right there is
always the well aside from the ending
moments which I think surpassed that but
in terms of the the individual moments
this game shows us oh I'm calm colliding
gives you so much euphoria you're always
feeling really good and boom just
another moment and finally a glimpse of
the society that was before you fall
below it and then I guess that takes us
to a close doesn't it this is the end of
this particular level yeah this is a
good area so that we don't well I mean
most people probably have played this
before as this game has been out for
several years but if you have not yet
played journey this is just another time
we're gonna tell you play journey you
know it's a tremendous experience from
beginning to end it a little bit long no
it's an hour and a half you know maybe
memorable you'll always remember it
again I think that you know there's that
you know it's possible you might not get
the emotional connection that people
like you and I get to it but even even
if not i think it's i think it's better
to play the game knowing that that's a
possibility rather than to stay away
because you don't think that you'll have
that connection and you don't need the
connection to enjoy it yes that's true
it's awesome and it's really fun and
it's a quick play so it definitely pick
it up if you if you can it's on ps4 now
and it's just a great experience from
that game company so great and thank you
guys for joining us on this magical
journey
Sue's in the best game yay all right
thanks guys I'll see you later hi
you